hello I'm Christopher Hine and today
we're going to be talking again about uh
a timi waza today a little more from the
receptive side of a timi waza and I'm
going to give you guys uh some ways to
train it that'll actually probably be
another video but I'm going to I'm going
to talk about showman and yokan and why
they're different and a a really
stupidly simple Revelation that I had um
several years back and and when I made
the Revelation I don't know some of you
are going to watch it and go why was
that a revelation but to me it was a big
deal so I'm going to share that with you
guys today and maybe it'll be a big deal
for you maybe you'll think I was silly
to take so long to realize that we're
going to talk about showman and yokan
and the difference between the two
positions and this is in receiving a
Timmy so we're talking about receiving a
Timmy this time I'm G call Josh over
here we're going to go to work Josh
[Music]
[Applause]
all right so let's talk about sh minucci
and yokam minui and the difference
between the two and I'm GNA I'm going to
tell you the thing that really hit my
mind is amazing several years back and
and I kind of feel stupid about that now
okay so as we know shanci position is
this position right okay if Josh were to
throw yokom manucci we're going to get
somehow like this right just throw it
off that back hand okay so we get
somehow like this right so the main
difference between Showman's stuff and
uh yokan stuff positionally is where my
arm is if he sticks his arm out stick
this one out okay if he sticks his arm
out this is yokan position stuff this is
showman position stuff yokan showman now
that might seem like who cares about it
but it's important because if you're
trying to understand the positions that
will follow after the attack knowing
that tells you a lot about the kinds of
answers you're going to get get for
showman attacks and you're going to get
for yokan attacks so yokan attacks I'm
always going to be inside position which
means I'm going to be filling this or
finding a way to transition outside of
this and that's what I'm going to do
from all yokan stuff from showman stuff
I already have basically the good
position so everything I'm going to do
is going to be about keeping the good
position so not transitioning out of
that position but keeping the good
position and so this is kind of an
important thing to understand because if
you realize this this means that iido
has sets of answers for either side of
the arm right so meaning if I'm here
then I'm trained with all the techniques
that follow for yokan if I'm here I'm
trained with all the techniques for
showman which means if Josh were to take
the showman and move his arm around oh
now we have the answers for yokan right
if he was to try to do something else
right something weird like maybe cut my
belly or something oh now we have all
the transitions for the showman the
outside stuff right so understanding
that showman and yokan are inside and
outside very iations of that arm
suppression kind of thing right and it's
it's like a really weak arm suppression
because it's not eeko yet um it will
become EO as soon as we can but it's not
quite there yet so that's really the big
difference between showman and yokan and
I think if you let that kind of sit in
your mind for a minute you'll kind of
realize oh there's a lot of cool stuff
in there okay now with that said let's
real talk real quickly talk about what
yokan is and then next week I'll make
you a whole series of these guys um CU
they're fun to look at so um let me have
you switch H me for me okay so when Josh
comes in We have basically a couple
timings of things right so look if I
knew Josh was going to hit me and I was
Sin Sin no sin I was I was ahead but I
could I could act before he could act
then I could just enter straight into
this boom I could hit him right and so
we kind of talked about that last week
with the what what happens if someone
kind of stops and stutters steps right
well you should just attack before they
can attack because you know attack is
imminent and they've cut that distance
down and they're working into their
ideal distance and I want to attack them
before they get their ideal distance so
that's what would happen if I'm way
ahead now if I'm way way behind then
well if I'm way way behind this will
happen Okay that's way way behind I
didn't even realize there was a strike
coming and I got hit but one up from
that that we can actually work with is
simply this okay which is Udan Kaku and
that's just bringing my arms up now in
iido you should be training yourself and
your students all the time when their
arms rais your arms raised so when I see
his arms go up my arms go up and that
means I've already accounted for any arm
up stuff now if from the arm up position
he decides to attack low well he brings
his arms down and I bring my arms down
right so we go up together we come down
together and if we keep that my arms are
always going to be creating suppression
for whatever he comes with okay now
somewhere in the middle of those way way
ahead and way way behind we have the
other options if we're just come a
little closer for me if we're close we
can use the sugii entry and my teacher
calls this the direct entry right but
I'm going to sugii off my front step so
as Josh comes in go here boom and I'm
hitting at Josh directly right so that
really only works well from a closer
position doesn't work well from regular
my ey because it's so far to go and so
what happens is when we get at regular
my ey not that I won't stop it but his
foot will make the full transition
through and this isn't that position
right so this is another position I have
to work with and we can talk about it
but it's not the ideal position so if
we're showing a form this isn't the way
we would do it so from from a closer
position I can generally get this off
before he can step that back foot and
that's going to set up most of the stuff
for the forms for that so that's still
pretty early but he has begun to go into
action okay now a little further away
from that and also um uh a little
further in distance and timing from that
is the aumi AI step so actually let me
have you switch for this one so when he
yashi in the yashi blend is this blend
okay now something I like to pick at
with this and really drives me nuts I
believe for me and my way of looking at
iido you should not be moving on a
circle with this person right so meaning
in a lot of IO schools this blo looks
like
this okay that to me is just about
useless right so look and I come in we
go like this just like that okay so
that's I love to show that all the time
um in iido schools there is really not
Marshall application to that um I guess
he didn't hit me which is cool but
there's no reason for me to do that now
opposed to that is the way I teach it
which is direct step in and circle at
the end now direct step in what happens
is I get and just go Um to the beginning
of the action then stop so here I've
stepped where Josh is weak and I'm
applying Force directly to Josh so I'm
moving him away at the same time I'm
covering my head so if anything comes in
I I defend that so when he comes in I go
right at him and then I turn at an angle
at the end so I hit the perfect angle to
knock him off of me so instead of
dancing around in a circle which is
really useless Josh gets nothing for
that right I want to be attacking in
that defense right so that's what I'm
looking for changing the line with that
so those are the basic um yokan defenses
you're going to see in iido forms you're
going to see direct entry you're going
to see a receptive or yashi entry a
sugii entry or you're going to see just
UD sankaku arms up and some variation of
udis sanaku depending on the timing
other than that you're either going to
hit them before they hit or they're
going to hit you before you can do
anything so those are all the timings of
that okay now from those there's tons of
other stuff we're going to get in that
the next video right so if we're in this
uh yokan position remember like I said
said in the beginning anytime I'm inside
that's a that's a yokan position so I
can get high pass or called ukos
sometimes or low pass gate on barai
right so um I can get either of those
off of that and those will pretty much
make up all the
forms yeah pretty much make up all the
forms we'll see for Yoko manucci uh so
I'm Christopher hin next week we'll put
another video talking about how to build
these all into a drill together that
will help you and we'll see you next
next time I'm Christopher Hines Joshua T
and Myon McDaniel right back there
a
[Music]